former FBI director james comey 'he's
trump memos hit the press president
Trump brings in Rudy Giuliani and we
checked the mailbag this is the ben
shapiro show
as always lots of breaking news today
James Comey he had those memos they
wrote contemporaneously when he was FBI
director and had conversations with
president-elect Trump and then President
Trump and now those memos if it the
press will go through them and tell you
everything that you need to know plus
he's bringing Rudy Giuliani but first I
want to tell you about our sponsors over
at zip recruiter so are you hiring right
now are you looking to make sure that
your business is constantly improving
are you just get rid of somebody you
need to fill a spot well this is what
zip recruiter is for zip recruiter
learns what you are looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job these invitations have
revolutionized how you will find your
next hire in fact 80% of all employers
who post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiter doesn't
actually stop there they even spot like
the strongest applications you receive
so you never miss a great match the
right candidates are out there and zip
recruiters how you find them it's the
reason we use if recruiter here at the
daily wire and here at the ben shapiro
show when we have to get rid of people
and then replace them with better people
so check it out my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free right now they can
try it for free go to zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire again that zip
recruiter comm slash daily where they
really do make things really easy they
ensure that you are only getting the
best applicants and they figure out
which are the best applicants for your
business they help you every step of the
way zip recruiter comm slash daily wired
go check it out and use that slash daily
wire so they know we sent you ok so
there's been hubbub for literally over a
year about James commis firing James
Comey was fired as head of the FBI
because James Comey refused to say that
President Trump was in the clear with
regard to the Russia investigation or at
least the president Trump was not under
investigation and Trump got mad about
that and so he fired James Comey he made
that pretty clear at the time well James
Comey immediately came out after that
just to recapitulate the history James
Comey came out after that and he leaked
some contemporaneous memos to one of his
friends a Columbia University law
professor he took these memos that he'd
written that were supposed to be notes
from meetings that he'd had with Trump
and he leaked them to one of his friends
said they'd get out in the press with
the express purpose of trying to get a
special prosecutor involved the idea
here was this that President Trump had
fired Comey
and now the DOJ had recommended that on
the basis of rod Rosen's teens remember
Jeff Sessions had recused himself from
everything Russia related
when that meant that rod Rosenstein the
Deputy Attorney General was the guy who
wrote a letter saying that James Comey
should be fired President Trump used
that letter as the basis for firing
James Comey James Comey then leaked a
bunch of memos about his relationship
with Trump to the press in the hopes
that the that Rosenstein would have to
recuse himself and appoint a special
prosecutor because once it became clear
that Trump had actually done this over
the Russia stuff and Rosenstein had been
involved in the firing of James call me
then suddenly a special prosecutor is
necessary that's why these memos became
a big issue in the first place
it was on the basis of these memos that
James Comey was called in front of
Congress to testify it was on the basis
of these memos that James Comey got his
big book deal and it's on the basis of
those memos that James Comey is now
running around on television every
single night so yesterday the DOJ turned
over these memos to Congress there's
some controversy related to this because
remember the DOJ had suggested that
originally these memos could not become
public because it would be a serious
infringement on national security
classified material would make it into
the public sphere if these if these
memos were to be made public there was
an ongoing investigation involving the
memos why should they be given to
Congress well yesterday they said fine
we'll hand him over to Congress and then
within five minutes of them being handed
over to Congress The Associated Press
have that had them the Washington Post
had them everybody in the press had them
and so here is what you need to know
from the Comey memos first of all
there's really nothing groundbreaking
about the Comey memos themselves so
everything that you knew that James
Comey had already said he said he said
in these memos
so his contemporaneous memos are very
consistent with what he's been saying
publicly
according to James Comey he went to
President Trump he told him about the
Russian dossier that was compiled by
Christopher Steele at the behest of
fusion GPS which was paid by the Hillary
Clinton campaign so try to follow me
here Hillary Clinton paid fusion GPS
which paid Christopher Steele to compile
a dossier on President Trump and that
dossier made its way to the FBI and
James Comey showed the most salacious
parts of that dossier to President Trump
and Trump and Comey at length discussed
the infamous p tape of course was the
portion of the dossier alleging that
President Trump went to Russia in 2013
and had Russian prostitutes pee on a bed
once occupied by the Obamas which is
real weird okay and then Trump
apparently told Comey at one point that
Putin had brags about the quality of
Russian hookers which is like okay
whatever and then
early Trump joked about jailing
reporters and Comey laughed about it and
Trump said that Michael Flint had
serious judgment issues which is not a
great shock ended up firing his national
security advisor Michael Flynn and then
asking James Comey if there was any way
he could see himself clearer to letting
Michael Flynn go which is not
obstruction since he didn't actually
pressure call me to let Michael Flynn go
so why do these memos matter why do
these memos matter well there are a few
reasons these memos matter so on the
Left they're suggesting these memos
matter because James Comey now looks
more consistent it looks like he's been
consistent in story throughout okay fair
enough but there are some problems for
James Comey in the memos hey first
problem for Jim's coming in the memos
first of all the memos themselves have
some reactions that means that some of
the material in the memos is still
classified well that raises a question
was Jim's call me leaking classified
material from his memos to the press if
so that's actually a crime now Comey
says he only leaked one memo to his
friends and that memo was unclassified
but we're gonna have to figure this
thing out because the fact is that
according to the letter from the DOJ to
Congress releasing these memos quote
pursuant to your request we are
providing the requested memoranda in
both redacted and unredacted formats for
your convenience the unredacted
documents are classified and will
provide those in a separate secure
transmittal to the House Security office
tomorrow which seems to imply that
commis memos were not all unclassified
okay also this seems to suggest that the
DOJ fibbed about the importance of the
memos in the first place as I mentioned
the DOJ refused to turn over the memos
when requested under the Freedom of
Information Act last year they claimed
that the release of the memos would
somehow impede the Muller investigation
nothing in the memo seems to suggest
this is true The Meadows also do not
suggest obstruction so this is a point
in favor of President Trump after the
release of the memos representatives
Devin Nunez Bob Goodlatte trey Gowdy
they tore into Comey
they said quote the memos show that the
president made clear he wanted
allegations of collusion coordination
and conspiracy between his campaign and
Russia fully investigated furthermore
the memos demonstrate the Trump didn't
want Russian and for election
interference investigation ended but the
suggestion that he had engaged in lewd
personal conduct he wanted investigated
so he was much more concerned with the
allegations about the P tape then he was
concerned about the idea that Russia
interfered in the election he wasn't
seeking to shut anything down or or
direct the investigation in any
particular direction except on the P
tape according to the Comey memos as the
congressman point out the memo is also
show
former director Comey never wrote that
he felt instructed or threatened which
is of course true he didn't feel
obstructed or threatened until he was
fired at which point it became sour
grapes maybe I was fired because of
obstruction as opposed to I was fired
because I'm wildly incompetent at my job
it is also true that these memos show
that James Comey held the Trump
administration and President Trump to a
different standard than he held members
of the Obama administration
so Comey has stated he interfered in the
Hillary Clinton email investigation in
an unprecedented way right he went out
there he did his big press conference
where he announced basically why hillary
clinton should be indicted and then said
she shouldn't be indicted he did that an
attempt to shield Loretta Lynch the
Attorney General from allegations of
bias or corruption well he never wrote
contemporaneous memos about his meetings
with Loretta Lynch or Barack Obama
during that time even though he was so
worried about it that he interfered in
the middle of an investigation
in a way that is wildly unprecedented he
only reserved those memos for Trump and
this is what the congressmen point out
they say quote he chose not to
memorialize conversations with President
Obama attorney general Lynch Secretary
Clinton Andrew McCabe or others but he
immediately began to memorialize
conversations with President Trump these
memos also lay bare the notion that
director former former director Comey is
not motivated by animus Comey also never
bothered to try to launch a Special
Counsel investigation against Lynch and
Clinton through leaks also worth noting
in these memos Comey defended McCabe
repeatedly and personally to President
Trump it now turns out that McCabe was
in fact lying repeatedly and now is
under criminal investigation that came
out yesterday that Andrew McCabe has
been now referred by the IG for criminal
investigation on the basis of leaking to
the press a bunch of stories about his
involvement in the Hillary Clinton
Foundation scandal and in his attempts
to investigate it so the Comey memos
don't actually help commis case in fact
they sort of hurt it they don't show us
anything we didn't already know but they
do undercut the case that Comey was
being pressured in any real way by
President Trump all of this prompted
President Trump to tweet so here's what
President Trump tweeted about all this
quote James Comey memos just out and
show clearly there was no collusion and
no obstruction also he leaked classified
information Wow will the witch-hunt
continue ok so again Joe I think it's
all advised for Trump to tweet this yes
but is he right yeah yes I mean there's
no inclusion no obstruction and it is
pretty clear that he may have leaked
classified information so all of this
this whole thing this whole
whole Special Counsel investigation
which was launched on the basis not not
the Russia investigation the special
counselor mother investigation which was
launched on the back of commis memos
seems really weak there's another theory
that is now being put out there by
modeling Malley Hemingway over at the
Federalist that is worth noting here
that what the memos really show is that
the the is that James Comey and James
clapper the former head of the CIA and
the press were in cahoots in their
attempts to get the the information
about the P tape out into the public
sphere so here's what Molly Hemingway
writes so she writes quote in multiple
memos Comey specifically mentioned that
CNN had the dossier the famous P tape
dossier and wanted a news hook that
would enable the network to report on
its most salacious allegations even
though they had not been verified so in
the memos it says that's quote I said
the Russians allegedly had tapes
involving him and prostitutes at the
presidential suite at the Ritz Carlton
in Moscow from about 2013 I said I
wasn't saying this was true only that I
wanted him to know both that had been
reported and that the reports were in
many hands no media organizations had
reported the allegations at the time
that Comey brief Trump's is Molly
Hemingway I said media like CNN and had
them and we're looking for a news hook
Comey added in his memo about the
briefing with Trump on January 6 2017 On
January 28th 2017 Comey wrote that in a
separate meeting Trump mentioned the
allegation about the alleged tape
prostitute of prostitutes of the hotel
and called it fake news Comey said I
explained again why I had thought it
important that he know about it I also
explained that one of the reasons we
told him was that the media CNN in
particular was telling us they were
about to run with it well this is all
weird why is this weird because on
January 10th just four days after James
Comey briefed the President of the
United States about the P tape there was
a CNN story and it said quote Intel
Chiefs presented Trump with claims of
Russian efforts to compromise him
extremely well-placed sources told CNN
that the Obama administration's top
intelligence appointees had briefed
Obama Biden and Trump all about a
dossier they took incredibly seriously
and considered credible but it sounded
really bad as the headline indicated CNN
declared Russian operatives claimed to
have compromising personal and financial
information about mr. Trump and just a
few minutes later BuzzFeed published the
actual dossier showing the world that
the dossier was riddled with salacious
gossip that lacked even a possibility of
corroboration
so remember here's the logic James Comey
and company right they told Trump that
we may have a
have a media scandal on our hands if
they can find a news hook and then what
a CNN uses the news hook the fact that
James Comey told President Trump that he
may have a media scandal on his hand you
see how the circuit the circular system
works here so I'll explain more of that
in just a second first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at ring so
our sponsors over at bring the video
doorbell company that allow you to see
and speak to anyone when they come to
your door they've actually sent us some
actual footage of ring busting crooks in
the act this one is just weird so this
is nighttime and a woman catches a
strange man standing at her door and
here is what ensues hey sorry we're in
the middle of dinner can I help you how
are you good how are you good seen you
in a while I don't know who you are I'm
Justin I met you okay so it's not clear
this guy's criminal but clearly this guy
is is weird and you really don't want
weirdos hanging out outside your house
without your able being able to see what
exactly is happening there this is one
of the reasons that you need a ring a
lot happens at your front door got a
ring video doorbell and you will never
miss a visitor whether you're home or
way you can see and speak to visitors on
your smartphone from anywhere even share
video clips to neighbors using the ring
app and we at our house we use room
we've used it for years now save up to
one hundred and fifty dollars on a ring
of security kit at ring.com slash Ben
that's ring.com slash Ben the ring of
security kit includes the ring
floodlight cam the spotlight cam it lets
you build a ring of security around your
entire property again you get a hundred
fifty bucks off when you go to ring comm
slash Ben that's ring comm slash Ben
again we use it at the Shapiro household
and it is invaluable I can tell you that
ring comm slash been for that discount
also so they know that we saw you okay
so back to the the reports about the
Comey memo that are really interesting
now this has not been substantiated but
the the going theory now on the right
seems to be that James Comey and company
went to president Trump and informed him
about the P tape dossier not just
because they wanted to inform him but
maybe because they wanted to leak the
news that that meeting had taken place
is that CNN could use it as a news hook
right this is what Molly Hemingway is
over at the federal she says keep in
mind that nothing we now know about the
dossier had been reported at the time it
wasn't yet reported that it was used by
the FBI to provide a substantial basis
to wiretap at least one Trump affiliate
despite the fact that it was unverified
it wasn't yet reported that the product
was bought and paid for as a Hillary
Clinton campaign operation or that it
was secretly funded by the DNC using the
law firm as a pass-through to hide its
provenance in federal campaign filings
after nearly a year of wrangling the
seven memos written by Comey were
finally handed over on Thursday to
Congress which oversees the operation
and funding of the FBI and DOJ the memos
purport to show commis version of in
turn his interactions with the president
before come--it was fired last May but
Molly Hemingway says listen something
weird is going on here right that Comey
claims the James clapper over at the CIA
wanted Trump to be briefed on the P tape
and on the on the dossier and in the
briefing Cohen in his notes he told
Trump CNN has this information they may
run with it at any time they just need a
news hook and the very news hook that
CNN used was Trump has now been briefed
about this stuff so it wasn't Comey then
that does raise some questions about
James clapper because clapper obviously
is a highly partisan player and if James
clapper was was basically using this as
an excuse to get the the the P tape
nonsense out there in the first place
that is pretty damning and very very
troubling
in any case none of this is particularly
troubling for President Trump I mean the
only material on the table right now
that could be serious problem for
President Trump is whatever the FBI's
got from Michael Cohen right that's the
stuff that could actually hurt President
Trump but this P tape stuff the dossier
stuff the Comey memos none of them
actually seem to be breaking at any
significant news James Comey still won't
leave our TV screens however because
he's got a book to show and and it's
amazing to watch as James Comey backs
off of his own strong position that
Trump may be compromised so he was asked
by Jake Tapper yesterday whether
President Trump has been compromised by
Russia now remember the reason that he
told President Trump about the P tape in
the first place is because of the
possibility that Trump might actually be
affected by so-called compromise right
James Comey says actually it's kind of
unlikely that Russia has that sort of
compromising information I'm not going
to talk about the investigation of
possible cooperation between Americans
and the Russian effort to influence our
election what you're asking about now is
why did I say what I said when people
asked me whether I thought it was
possible that the Russians had
derogatory information on President
Trump I think it's unlikely but I think
it's possible unlikely but possible it's
different from what he said earlier
which is he said it was just possible
but now it's unlikely but possible
bottom line is Comey has no news to
break in the media are struggling for
news well in their struggle for news
James Comey tried to bring out another
piece of information yesterday and I'm
gonna explain that one here so President
so James Comey says that in the memos
Trump told him that he talked with Putin
about hookers so according to the memos
James Comey told Trump about the P tape
allegations and Trump responded by
saying that he had not spent the night
in Russia that may or may not be true
and then Trump said that he doesn't need
hookers because he's very famous
probably true and then James Comey said
to Trump that in and then Trump said to
James call me that Vladimir Putin does
vouch for the hookers over in Russia
okay so James Comey is trying to break
this is a big piece of news and then we
will explain why Trump probably said
this in the first place I can't recall I
think there was public reporting that he
had spoken to Vladimir Putin as sort of
a welcome heel congratulations on taking
office thing at that point I'm not
suggesting they talked about how
beautiful the hookers were and in Russia
but but I do know there was at least one
publicly reported conversation so what
exactly happened with the hookers why
exactly did Trump say that in the first
place to to combing probably because of
just a few days beforehand Vladimir
Putin had announced to the world that
Russia has the best hookers this
happened about like a week and a half
before Trump told Comey about Putin
talking about hookers the chance is that
Putin actually talk directly with Trump
about hookers are extraordinarily low
but he did speaks the world bad hookers
which is weird so here is Vladimir Putin
at the time talking about how great
hookers were in Russia with our girls of
reducing social responsibilities I love
that euphemism that's so that although
here we also have the best ones in the
world and to Vladimir Putin when you're
talking about prostitutes and you're
bragging about the quality of your
prostitutes that is one leader of a
country right there that is probably why
Trump said that not because Putin
actually told Trump that the hookers in
Russia were actually the best ok so
meanwhile the other breaking news from
all of the all of the Trump Russia stuff
is that apparently Rudy Giuliani
has now joined the team Rudy Guiliani of
course was very close with the Trump
campaign he's very involved in the Trump
campaign is a very close and weird
relationship with President Trump going
back years in fact here are some early
audio and video of President Trump then
just Donald Trump with the mullet I mean
really business and front partying back
and and Rudy Giuliani is about 1990 I
believe you know you're really beautiful
a woman that looks like that really
onions dress her wig and facials by the
way okay and then Trump actually says
well you can't blame me for trying or at
least I tried and then later apparently
he would talk about this with Billy Bush
right hey he moved on Rudy Giuliani very
heavily he moved on him like like a
bleep okay in any case everything is
very weird Rudy Giuliani is joining the
team because Giuliani does have some
legal knowledge obviously he was he was
a prosecutor and so he's joining the
legal team in an effort to try and
negotiate an end to the mall or probe
that doesn't seem wildly out of bounds
it doesn't seem out of the realm of
possibility either because I'm not sure
that Muller actually has anything so far
as this Russia collusion stuff goes and
the obstruction case is extremely weak
if but if by obstruction you mean that
he fired James Comey even James Comey
can't say that it was obstruction makes
it very difficult to claim that there is
serious obstruction by Team Trump now
again the real danger to President Trump
is not that the real danger to President
Trump is in the Michael Cohen stuff in
the fact that his personal lawyers
offices were rated on the basis of
supposed campaign finance violations
Alan Dershowitz who's been you know a
pretty strong legal ally for president
Trump throughout this process
he says that President Trump has to
assume that people are going to flip on
him
prosecution has an enormous leverage
they can charge you with a dozen crimes
even if they're relatively technical
crimes that accumulate with the
guidelines and tell you you're going to
never see freedom again you're going to
serve the rest of your life in prison
kind of pressure brings about not only
singing but sometimes composing I think
the president has to assume that his
closest friends his greatest associates
that people he trusts the most if
exposed to the pressure the risk of life
imprisonment will flip that has to be
his working assumption okay so then the
question becomes what exactly does
Michael Cohen have on presidents from
maybe the answer is nothing but that's
the place where Trump really has
vulnerability legally the Muller
investigations gonna come to nothing and
I think that Trump knows that I think
team Trump knows that I think that's why
they're being cooperative with Muller I
think that's why Trump is is really not
concerned with firing Muller because all
of that after a year and a half of this
nonsense will finally come to an
inglorious end it'll really be on the
Michael Cohen investigation Democrats
are now gonna have to shift their hopes
from Trump Russia collusion to Michael
Kohn engaging in some sort of illegal
activity with Trump in order to push
their impeachment hopes ok so meanwhile
I just have to tell you the story then
we'll get to the mailbag because I want
to do some mail bagging it up today but
this is an amazing story so you remember
that DC lawmaker Trey on white so Tran
white is a Democrat from Ward 8 in in
Washington DC as a council member and he
had said if you recall that the weather
was controlled by the Jews he blamed the
Jews for the weather in Washington DC
was a real weird thing like we the Jews
the Jordan we control many things but we
do not control the weather as far as I'm
aware if not I'll have to talk to the
Elders of Zion about it and my friend
and I meeting I mean it's it's already
Friday so I figured tonight we'll get
together and we'll talk about whether we
can control the weather because if so
then there are a few places that ought
to be hit with lightning but if not it's
real weird so Trey on white in an
attempt to do penance for this went to
the Holocaust Museum in Washington DC so
he said that he was he apparently spent
some time on this tour and it got very
weird so he suggested that an image of a
German girl being marched through the
streets of Norden in 1935 is humiliation
for an alleged relationship of the Jew
was actually depicting her being
protected by Nazi troops surrounding her
there's a picture of a German woman
wearing a sign around her neck being
paraded through the streets and the sign
says I slept with the Jew basically and
this and this idiot tray on white
actually thought that this was the Nazis
protecting this woman from the
population outside which is very very
weird and that's when the museum experts
pointed out that this was untrue and
then it apparently got weirder and
weirder
apparently he he suggested that the
Warsaw Ghetto was a gated community I'm
not joking about this is an actual thing
that happened so he he said that the he
was that he saw a picture of the Warsaw
Ghetto he said oh yeah it's just like a
gated community um no it was more like a
giant open-air prison so there was that
that's why there's an uprising there I
love that he did this like on the
anniversary of the Warsaw Ghetto
Uprising just tremendous and awareness
here the other thing that I love about
this of course is that the the national
media coverage has been relatively scant
so it was covered by the Washington Post
it was covered by media it-- but if this
had been a Republican lawmaker of any
caliber it would be all over the front
pages of every newspaper that this
person went to a Holocaust Museum and
thought that the Warsaw Ghetto was a
gated community just absolutely asinine
but demonstrating once again that
political correctness only runs in one
direction okay time for the mailbag so
if you have questions now is the time
for the Nikolas says quote men I'm
currently in the Marines I've been
living overseas for the past couple of
years I was recently having a discussion
with another marine about our founding
fathers and their statues across the
country as a minority and someone who
had ancestors that were slaves he can't
bring himself to respect them and
doesn't understand why we still have
statues honoring them yes why in the
world should a modern day person of
color in America want statues of slave
owners still all over the country I've
always had a passion for American
history and have revered our founding
fathers but I'm starting to rethink my
position as I look at it from his point
of view well listen I totally understand
why people of color or people who have
ancestors who were slaves would be the
upset with the idea of statues of people
who held slaves with that said the
reason that we're honoring Thomas
Jefferson is not because he held slaves
the reason that we're honoring Thomas
Jefferson is because Thomas Jefferson
was the author of the Declaration of
Independence the creator of the
Louisiana Purchase a president who stood
for states rights and an instrumental in
the drawing of the Constitution of the
United States that's why we honor Thomas
Jefferson we don't honor him for a slave
holding this is like somebody's like a
woman saying about Martin Luther King
you know Martin Luther King that statue
right there you know I understand that
Martin Luther King was did some great
things the Martin Luther King was also
really really nasty about women like I
mean Martin Luther King had a very bad
record of philandering with regard to
his wife and as a woman it makes me very
upset to see that statue of Martin
Luther King well the answer to that is
that's
why we honor Martin Luther King so
recognizing that we build statues to
people for the things that they do well
not for the things they do badly
and yet that people are rounded human
beings who do bad things sometimes I
think it's really important I think that
statues generally should be taken as
jumping-off points for having exactly
these sorts of discussions but
pretending that honoring Jefferson with
the Jefferson Memorial for example is
honor and slavery is just silly it's
just not true it's like saying that the
Lincoln Memorial but the honoring
Abraham Lincoln is really about honoring
his original sentiments with regard to
the inferiority of black people if you
go back and read Abraham Lincoln in 1856
he was staying openly that he didn't
think the black people were of the same
capacity as white people but that's not
why we honor him we honor him because of
the Emancipation Proclamation and his
belief in the end the black Americans
were Americans and these were American
citizens and these people should be
freed from slavery and so what we choose
to honor people about doesn't obscure
the rest of their history but we should
recognize that us honoring Thomas
Jefferson or George Washington is about
honoring their achievements not about
honoring their demerits and that we can
discuss those demerits in the same
breath as those achievements and
recognize that people were people who
lived up their time is also relevant to
note that with regard to slavery
virtually everyone virtually everyone
for thousands of years was living in a
slaveholding society and again there are
lots of people who today I think are
real garbage but we still honor their
works of art and then how many how many
artists do we know who are just bad
people like rotten human beings but we
still recognize that they made a good
movie how many politicians leave a woman
to die the bottom of a river and in your
honor called the line of the Senate in
other words when you look at human
beings it is worthwhile to look at them
in their entirety but when you're
looking at the monument the monument is
really to the achievements of human
beings Nix has been what is your stance
on global warming
now climate change I know a lot of
conservatives seems to be split on the
issue I have heard you before say that
you would like to do more research on
the issue before you discuss it but I'd
really like to know your opinion there's
a big issue between my friends and me we
discuss this regularly
listen you every morning keep up the
good work okay so Nick here is my
feeling on this my feeling is that
global warming they're they're really a
couple of issues one is is climate
change taking place and the answer is
yes climate change is taking place
virtually everyone agrees climate change
is taking place the second question is
how much is man
activity responsible for that climate
change in other words what is the
sensitivity of the climate to carbon
emissions for example that's slightly
more controversial there are some
scientists who say that it's 50% of all
climate change is attributable to
mankind there are people who say 90%
there people who say 30% I don't know
the answer to that I would assume that
it is a non insignificant percentage is
attributable to man-made activity and
then finally there's the third question
which is what should we do about it and
the what should we do about a question
is really the hardest because I've
noticed that there's this kind of nasty
conflation that happens all the time on
the global warming argument which is if
I say to you that I agree with the IPCC
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change that there will be a seven degree
fahrenheit change in the average global
climate by the year 2100 if I say I
agree with you I agree with all of you
the premises of this if I say to you
that this is going to mean that things
change on the globe but if I also say to
you listen I think that your solutions
like the Paris Accords are not actually
going to make enough of a difference to
be worth sacrificing trillions of
dollars in future income and development
in a wide variety of developing
countries so really what we should do is
what the market handle it and we should
aid people who need to move from
particular areas if climate threatens
they're the places that they live the
population movement and transition due
to climate change has been true as long
as human beings have been on planet
earth if I say that then you say well
you're denying climate change well no
I'm not denying climate change I'm just
saying it happens but my solution may
not be your solution and I think that we
ought to analyze whether a particular
solution is actually calibrated to do
good or whether it is just virtuous
signaling in an attempt to redistribute
wealth which so many of these climate
change solutions seem to be Sheamus has
been what are your thoughts on Pope
Francis so you know I I was a big fan of
Pope John Paul - I was a big fan of Pope
Benedict I am NOT a big fan of Pope
Francis I think the Pope Francis seems
to me to be an emissary of liberation
theology the left wing of the of the
South American Catholic movement that
suggests that social justice and and
Catholicism are are one in the same I
don't think that this is correct
you know I it's hard to tell honestly
what he's saying sometimes because
obviously he speaks a different language
than I do and beyond that some of the
reporting is is inaccurate so sometimes
you'll see people report things like
Pope Francis says there's no hell and
then it turns out that it was just an
eight
his newspaper in Italy and they were
misconstruing what he was saying if you
were to believe what the left believes
about Pope Francis I would say that I'm
not as fond of him as Pope if you were
to believe you know what the right says
about him then maybe he's fine but III
will say that the headlines that I've
seen him make some of the things that he
said about foreign policy some of the
things that he said about immigration
some of the stuff that he said about the
the environment I I don't find any of
this to be deeply tied into theological
concerns I think it's much more
political than theological women says I
want to be a teacher and I'm toying with
the idea of pursuing a PhD in social
science education what are your thoughts
on PhDs
well my thought on PhD is that if it's
useful it's useful you know I'm not sure
that that it's a matter of one PhD being
a grand thing versus a terrible thing is
it useful to you then do it if it's not
useful to you then don't do it but I
don't think it could be HD necessarily
confers a tremendous amount of expertise
depending on what you're getting your
PhD in and what your dissertation is
about maybe the way that you get your
dissertation is by taking some classes
and then writing a giant paper basically
and that doesn't make you an expert on
everything having to do with social
science obviously okay so we're gonna do
some more mail bagging it up but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire comm and subscribe $9.99 a month
gets you subscriptions who daily wire
and gets you the rest of this show live
it gets you the mailbag access you can
now ask questions
it gets you the rest of the Andrew
Clavin show live there are some Michael
Mosley's show live we have some more
goodies coming and if you get the annual
subscription for 99 dollars a year you
got this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels the leftist Cheers hot
or cold daily wire sponsored incredible
beverage vessel you get this and it will
make your life that much better listen
our producer is running on virtually
empty at this point but all he has to do
is swig from this beverage vessel and
suddenly he will be infused the new sort
of energy yes I'm talking about you math
it's you two can live like Malthus if
you get the annual subscription but be
happier but not your hair won't be as
good ninety nine dollars a year that's
all that will get you the subscription
if you just want to listen later go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube
subscribe leave a serve you we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
core and conservative podcast in the
nation
all righty more mailbag so William asks
what can conservatives do to participate
more in education and bring a diversity
of thoughts of public education well
this is a real difficult thing because
many states require the be member of
Teachers Union in order for you to teach
right California is one of these states
and that means the teachers unions are
obviously taking money from your
paycheck and then using it for biased
political curricula you can do your best
to teach straight politics I would say
start a private school honestly as far
as the public education system I think
that it's it's run by the government and
as Ludwig von Mises suggested about
bureaucracy once a bureaucracy is owned
by the state it is very difficult for it
not to promulgate the the the strength
of the state once you are being paid by
the state your interest obviously is in
maximizing the power of the state
michael says men my question is this my
daughter is a freshman in high school
and over the summer I would like her to
be reading material that will help
prepare her to think critically
philosophically and with purpose I'm
looking for suggestions of material that
would aid in this political philosophy
general philosophy history mythology etc
anything that would allow her to think
independently and critically which seems
to be lacking in today's public school
education so the number one book I
always recommend is there's a book by
Henry Hazlitt called economics in one
lesson it's about 150 pages long and it
teaches you to think very solidly about
economics in a very short period of time
basically all of economics is about
recognizing that there are unintended
consequences to the policies that you
pursue that book economics in one lesson
begins with the broken windows conundrum
basically they here's the here's the
question
you are a mayor of a city and there's a
criminal on the loose in the city and
this criminal is throwing rocks through
plate-glass windows is the criminal
hurting the economy or helping the
economy now folks on the Left would
actually say the criminal is helping the
economy why because now that criminal
has broken the window and the business
owner is gonna have to pay the glass
manufacturer in order to fix the window
when hazlit points out is of course this
is not true that the criminal is of
course hurting the economy because that
Baker who had his window broken could
have been spending that money on hiring
more employees to make more Goods and
making his price cheaper could have been
spending his money to repaint the place
could have been spending his money on a
yacht right bottom line is when you get
to choose the products you consume the
economy runs better and to you more to
your pleasure than when the government
controls what it is that you are
consuming and what you must
consume that's the kind of thinking that
goes into economics and one mustn't
check it out that's that's book number
one all right and then I would recommend
a history of the American a history of
America the American people by Paul
Johnson that is definitely worth reading
there there are a lot of great books I
think we have a book list on the site if
not we're gonna put one up pretty soon I
promising that for a long time I know we
have one at the office that we if you
email me I'll send it to you but let's
see someone else
anonymous writes Ben I'm a white
Catholic male and I'm going to be having
my first son come September I'm excited
but very nervous knowing that in the
state of our country who will instantly
be seen as privileged any ideas on how
to combat these new white stereotypes or
advice on raising any son would help
thank you first of all your son is
privileged if he was born into a
two-parent family right that is a
privilege he's born into the United
States that is a privilege does that
mean that you should be guilty for that
privilege hell no it's not his fault
what color he's born and why should you
be guilty about being born in the
greatest country in the history of
mankind why should you be guilty about
making sure that your son is born into a
two-parent family that is a wonderful
thing you did something right you made a
good decision good for you and your son
shouldn't feel guilty about you making a
good decision the idea that you are
guilty for making good decisions is so
stupid it's really interesting there's a
story that I saw the other day that was
widely covered about a woman who had
graduated in law school and she had I
think it was five children five children
she's a single mom and I believe that
the story was that she was never married
in the first place I think if not then
the story's irrelevant but let's assume
for the sake of argument is immediate
though this all the time that the media
glorifies single motherhood in a way
that no one else does right the media
will suggest that a woman who has a
child and she's not married and then she
overcomes the obstacles like having a
child in order to succeed in business
and somehow greater than the woman who
actually made the decision to get
married this drives me up a wall
privilege of decision making is what
matters in the United States in a free
country the decisions that you make
ought to have an impact on how you live
if you choose to get married before you
have a child that is something you did
right and we should be celebrating that
a lot more than the person who had a
child out of wedlock and then succeed
it's great that the woman who had a
child out of wedlock succeeds but she
did set up an obstacle to herself she
did set up an obstacle to herself in
terms of succeeding because now she
obviously has higher cost chance to do
childcare and she's deprived her kid of
a father in the home so you know this is
this is why responsible
decision-making matters it really does
Joseph has been what do Jews think of
contraception so this is rather
controversial there are a bunch of
different commentaries and and rulings
on contraception the general rule on
contraception according to orthodoxy as
I understand it is the contraception is
forbidden except in cases of health it
is relatively widely prescribed it
depends on the type of contraception so
in Judaism the birth control pill is is
recommended more highly over
prophylactics
for example Martha's Ben fan here from
tax achoo sits I have a question for you
regarding end-of-life care in the role
of government Medicare Medicaid
generally when a family can no longer
care for an elderly person they are
cared for in a nursing home under
Medicaid and the state absorbs the
little money they have left in any
monthly benefit checks is there actually
a viable solution to the extremely
expensive the end-of-life care that does
not involve a government intervention
well I mean sure just the same as it
would in the medical system which is you
save up a lot of money that did not go
to Social Security and taxes from
Medicare and Medicaid and you set that
aside for the day that the end of life
when is gonna cost a lot of money plus
when you don't have government subsidies
and when you don't have mandates that
are crammed down on on doctors to
prescribe certain things then
competition should lower the cost so the
faster one of the fastest-growing
industries in the United States for
example or assisted living facilities in
the private sector and because there's a
lot of competition in assisted living
facilities the prices have actually been
dropping pretty precipitously in certain
areas of assisted living facilities in
certain areas they're growing because
the demand is outstripping the supply
but that's just going to lead to more
supply supply and demand don't cease to
work just because the cost of a
particular product is particularly high
Daniel says hey Ben if slavery and
indentured servitude are outlawed by the
Thirteenth Amendment
why is jury duty legal Thanks have a
great Shabbat okay so the answer is
because jury duty is also covered by the
it's also covered by the Constitution of
the United States and the real answer is
because there are certain obligations
that you have as a citizen they come
along with citizenship and that don't
really fall under the purview of slavery
so jury duty is one of those being
drafted into the military is another one
of those but these are controversial
propositions
I think libertarians would probably
argue there shouldn't be jury duty the
libertarians might argue that you should
pay people to be on juries which i think
is actually not a terrible argument okay
someone else writes here hey Ben what do
you think is the cause of the country's
rampant anxiety and depression lack of
religion is rachel lack of purpose too
much south
I mean all of the above I think that
lack of purpose is tied up with lack of
religion I think it's tied up with lack
of values I think it's tied up with a
country where we've all determined to
see ourselves as victims rather than
active players in our own lives and if
we get beyond that if we determine that
the decisions we make in our own lives
are important and that we're not victims
of circumstance and that it is our job
to seek the purpose that we are to live
out right we are we are here to better
the world in accordance with our reason
as Aristotle would put it or we're here
to live out God's will for us as
judeo-christian values would put it I
think that would alleviate a lot of this
just I think that so much of our culture
is also designed to make you jealous of
other people's material belongings
people tend to get depressed about their
lack of material success when in reality
success is not dependent on the amount
of money that you make you know my dad
spent a lot of my life not earning a lot
of money and I would say that he's a
very successful human being because he
also raised four fantastic kids Danny
says hi Ben Danny here I'm partly a
german descent which is something i've
always been somewhat proud of I wonder
if you think there's still any room for
that type of pride considering Germany's
history do you agree with Knowles's
statement made last week that Germany is
the worst country in the world well I
think that it depends on time so I think
that to label Germany the worst country
in the world as though there is a unique
sort of German character is relatively
inaccurate because Germany was only
constituted formally in the middle of
the 19th century as one state before
that it was several states right it was
it was Prussia and it was what was a
very and various other principality but
the the notion that Germany is the worst
country in the world now I think is only
obviously it's not it's not Afghanistan
right it's not Iran it's not North Korea
the idea that Germany was the worst
country in the world in say 1805 I think
is silly considering that Napoleonic
France was still on the rise that it was
the worst country during the French
Revolution that obviously is not true so
countries change right some countries
are good at certain times and bad at
certain times Germany has a very
checkered history but to ignore the
achievements of some Germans and pretend
that you know it's not the country that
brought you Beethoven and Brahms and
Bach and all and then to suggest in the
same breath that Germany is responsible
for the Nazis again you know as I said
about individual human beings a little
bit earlier it's also true of countries
countries can be good countries can be
bad countries sin we should look at all
of these things in in relation to one
another without just labeling the entire
country crap Thomas says hi Ben
then you shed some light on the
difference between the soul and the
spirit thanks so in Judaism there is a
difference between the soul which is the
neshamah and the spirit which is the
nephesh the the the soul is is sort of
what makes you unique and the Spirit is
what animates you it's right it's the
life force within you would be the easy
way of describing it I think okay so a
couple of more questions here Frank says
hey Ben I've heard you mentioned this
States do you have for rock music I was
wondering would you look at it and it
better if it had a more conservative
values included in its lyrics or is it
the evolution of the instrumental sound
it gives off much love and respect Frank
well I think both I mean first of all I
think the values of rock music are
essentially garbage and have been
garbage for decades but as far as the
music itself listen I'm not gonna
pretend there aren't some rock bands
that I like I mean I like the Doobie
Brothers went to a concert a few weeks
ago with the Doobie Brothers I like
Chicago I like some of the old school
like 1960s 1970s rock bands I think some
of those are actually pretty good and
pretty creative you know Stevie Wonder I
think is a tremendous musician but what
I what I hate is that lack of musicality
in rock music as compared to other forms
of music even jazz is pretty astonishing
on every level Michael says hi Bette I
wanted to hear your opinion on the
possibility of President Trump
reinstating the draft if any further
conflicts in Russia and Syria were to
escalate to a world war three type
scenario that or if a war broke out
between the states and someone like Iran
or North Korea do you think there's a
realistic chance he would be President
and restore the draft do you think
society at large would cooperate well I
mean if there were a draft I think
people would cooperate if is the
president gonna restore the draft no I
think the draft is a thing of the past
no the fact is that we we have a pretty
large standing military and the best way
to increase the size of that military
would be to offer people more money to
join it presumably as opposed to
reinstating the draft more broadly
alrighty so now a couple of the things
that I like or the thing I like and then
maybe one thing that I hate here so
thing I like so I have there's a guy who
I recently met named Bryan Keating he is
a professor of cosmology over at
University of California San Diego he
has a brand new book coming out next
week it is really good it's called
losing the Nobel Prize the story of
cosmology ambition and the perils of
science as high as to honor the book is
really pitched as a critique of the
Nobel Prize and why the Nobel Prize is
corrupt
but the book really is is a really
fascinating history into the
investigation of the universe the Big
Bang
and the the theory that the universe has
been here in perpetuity it's it's really
a good user-friendly history I'm not
gonna say it's it's not difficult at
certain points it definitely is but you
know I think Brian really dumps it down
to the point where folks like me who
don't have a tremendous scientific
background can understand it the book is
losing the Nobel Prize so if you've ever
wondered how it is that we discovered
the Big Bang and what cosmic background
radiation is some of the terms of that
are used by astronomers then this book
is really good for that also it has some
pretty interesting discussions of
religion and science so check it out
losing the Nobel Prize by Bryan Keating
I can pre-order it on Amazon right now
and it should arrive sometime next week
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
okay so first of all I think that to
look in the United States for incidents
of racism is not all that difficult I do
think that there are people who are
doing racist things and they're doing
them on a not infrequent basis now we
have to take that as a percentage of the
population but the reason that I want to
show this is because there's been so
much focus put on what happened at
Starbucks in which two black guys were
allegedly told that they had to leave
the restaurant refused to leave the
restaurant after not buying anything
demanding to use the bathroom then were
arrested and there's become a national
issue on Good Morning America here's an
actual racist thing okay so this
happened over at Syracuse University and
there was an idiotic frat party and the
frat brothers did stuff that idiotic
frat brothers do which is they said a
bunch of racist anti-semitic
stupid crap and this is not getting the
sort of national attention that the
Starbucks thing did which is amazing
because this is absolutely clearly an
indication of racist rhetoric for
example tonight video from inside a
Syracuse fraternity sparking outrage
we're not showing the full disturbing
video obtained by the school paper but
the university calls it and additional
videos in its possession extremely
racist anti-semitic homophobic sexist
and hostile to people with disabilities
[Music]
always have a tree oh my heart hatred
the students in the video go on to say
for black people Hispanics and Jews the
university sending out a letter about
the video Wednesday morning suspending
the school's Theta Tau chapter but
declining to release other videos okay
so this stuff is obviously idiotic this
is one of the dangers of the alt right
that I was talking about last year is
because political correctness has taken
so much precedence at colleges all over
the United States they're a bunch of
people who think that the way to fight
political correctness is to be a piece
of crap and this is obviously a case of
that happening at Syracuse I also point
this out because again if you want to
talk about this sort of you know racism
as a response to political correctness
or if you want to talk about racism
existing in American society stuff like
this is pretty obvious case but instead
we're focusing on this Starbucks case
which I think is a lot less obvious I
think the reason for that is because
there are some folks on the Left who
like to pick controversial cases and
make them national issues specifically
because they know it'll draw opposition
or if you say that the Syracuse tape is
racist everyone says you're right that's
racist but if you say the Starbucks
incident where we still don't have tape
was racist and somebody says well you
know I'd like to see like the whole tape
but that they go up you know the reason
that you're not paying attention to that
incident is because you're a covertly
racist I hate that kind of stuff it's
really stupid okay asking for more
evidence when the evidence is not
sufficient is not racist but asking for
more evidence and when the evidence is
there like here right and I'm more than
happy to say Theta Tau should be
suspended right this is got it they've
got a serious problem over at Syracuse
University with this with this
fraternity that these kids are acting at
the very least like idiots and at the
very most like reprehensible human
beings so it's just um yeah again I
think that if we're all gonna be on the
same side then we can all be on the side
of against racism all I ask is some
evidence here you have evidence so I'm
on the side all right so we will be back
here next week with all of the latest
have a wonderful weekend I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
mic Carmina hair and makeup is by Joshua
Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright floor publishing 2018